[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony em
[Music]
I'm gonna try to do this without getting
totally pissed today
[Music]
we'll have to be pissed off about
guess it's better to be pissed off than
pissed on huh
of course
Republican scumbags want to try to
change the debate ow don't politicize it
don't politicize it now we're gonna
politicize the trans issue though
So Yesterday
um well let me start by telling you this
the reason why it is going to be very
difficult for me not to get totally
pissed off today
is because I have a daughter who is in
third grade
the same age as the children who were
mowed down yesterday by automatic
weapons that Republicans refuse
absolutely refuse
to even acknowledge that that is the
reason why children are dying in this
country the main reason
it's not car accidents not cancer it's
guns
and I I honestly I don't want my kids to
grow up too quickly no one does you
don't want your kids to grow up too
quickly
you want them to stay cute and little
forever and innocent right like that's
what you want
that's what you want
you can't always have that but that's
what you want
I'm telling you I'm gonna try not to get
too pissed off
but there is there's a sense in this
country and I thought about it a lot
yesterday after I left the show
and seeing the reports of who the
shooter was what motivation was what the
weapons were
mental illness trans issues I mean it's
all it's all just
nonsense
locked doors side doors
and I couldn't help but think to myself
over and over and over again I cannot
wait until my children
are adults to wear grocery stores is
what they have to worry about not not
elementary schools not high schools not
college campuses
what in the
is wrong with us
some Tennessee Congressman some
I I can't even
I'm trying not to get pissed off
I'm trying my damnedest
says that there's nothing they can do
not a goddamn thing
nothing they can do that's why he
homeschools his children
I think what we should do
is we should plaster the pictures
just like Emmett Till plaster the
pictures of these slaughtered children
everywhere
obviously this country has just not got
the message
obviously this country just does not
value
children's lives and I actually don't
believe that
I don't believe that the majority of
this country doesn't value children
doesn't value the safety of them in any
school I don't give a how against
it I am
I am not necessarily for
private Christian Schools but that's
their Liberty
and it is the liberty of those little
children those teachers and their
parents to make sure that those
students are safe
I don't give a what door is
unlocked I don't give a good God damn if
the building's secure I don't give a
if they're security guards in that
goddamn building I don't give a
I don't give a who's got the gun
or what kind of mental illness
they may have or may not have I don't
give a
I'm trying not to get pissed off
listen your Second Amendment
that you think you got
that you think you have
does not supersede my child's life
does not supersede those three children
that died in Nashville yesterday
I don't give a what school it's in
I'm against voucher schools but I'm damn
sure not for anyone going in about your
school with a gun
you
these are nine-year-olds
they're nine-year-olds
they got ripped apart by a weapon
that is used in combat
are you not paying the attention
yesterday Fox News
immediately went to the locked side door
did they lock the door did they lock the
door
more door reform you you you
dirty vile pieces of garbage
anyone any I mean anyone
anyone out there talking about a
door being locked or it's a school you
when I was in school they didn't lock
any of the doors
I went to elementary school in the
90s
not that long ago
yes guess what there was in the
90s
there weren't locked doors but there was
a goddamn semi-automatic weapons ban you
pieces of
your locked doors you
and your second amendment your
second amendment you you dirty sons of
these are these are
little babies
and they they we send them to school
public private Christian
as parents
and and they think they're supposed to
be safe today all around the country
children because yesterday three
children in Nashville got
slaughtered there's children all around
the country now
having to do drills for someone to come
in and kill them
with a gun that you just can't
go without
you God damn snowflakes you
you you
Freedom hating bastards
you think you think you're right to own
some stupid kind of weapon
because you want to be able to kill
people that's right that's right I don't
give a what you say you can say
whatever you want you can argue
with me until now until Kingdom Come
that weapon is not for
recreation it's not for protection you
don't have those kind of enemies
you goddamn piece of
listen if you don't get to the
table and start negotiating
gun reform this country is going to take
those away from you that's
right I'm here to tell you this country
eventually one of these days is going to
take away your guns you dumb
they're gonna do it they're
gonna do it
they're gonna do it I'm not against the
right to owning a weapon
Jesus Christ I grew up in a house with
rifles
we kept our doors unlocked
we left the keys in the car in
our in our driveway those weapons were
not for protection of our property or
ourselves
this disease that is running
rampant around the country
and it's it's not it's it's not the
mental illness that causes someone to go
shoot somebody that's not the disease
I'm talking about
everyone has mental illness I hate to
break it to you I hate to break it to
you people who are talking about mental
illness today you got one too it's
called I don't know we're human
people who have mental illness aren't
violent
there's more people who have mental
illness than own a gun
you stupid
it's the gun
it's the mother gun it's the gun
it's the God damn gun
and they're children they're
being killed by these guns
over and over and over we do this
and you 2A Bros out there who think
you're gonna use your gun to save your
Second Amendment right to have weapons
of war you are a dumb
that's right you are a dumb
there's a whole generation that is
coming up that is not going to put up
with this
being trained to hide underneath their
desks so their bodies aren't ripped
apart so their heads aren't blown off
you think they're not gonna you think
they're not gonna take away your
guns you are a stupid son of a let
me tell you something when I was a kid
in elementary school we did tornado
drills
and if there was a way if there was a
way to legislate tornadoes out of
existence you would be all
over it
we would do it yesterday
here we are today
three more children slaughtered how many
today huh how many today are you willing
to sacrifice for your for your rat it's
not your right to own weapons of
war
it says well-regulated
and we we the government we us
it's a republic it's us
thank you
we can regulate your right to own
firearms
you don't like it oh well leave it then
try going somewhere else in the world
try it see see see where else in the
world
I mean you can go to the Middle East
sure
a lot of places in the Middle East don't
have regulations on weapons
try to go somewhere
in this world
I mean you want to go be a member of the
cartel in Mexico I mean technically if
we make sure that we stop the
manufacturing of all these guns
and pile these guns on the street the
cartel will be out of weapons in no time
where the do you think they get the
guns you people bitching about the
cartel how do you where the do you
think they get their Weaponry they don't
get it in Mexico you stupid they
come here and anyone can buy anything at
any time they didn't and they'll take it
right across the border and I'm not
talking into our country out of our
country
foreign
the majority of Americans do not want
their children slaughtered in schools
the majority Americans do not want to
run and hide in the vegetable department
at their local grocery store most people
do not want to crouch down behind the
underwear section in Walmart
because you just gotta own you a
gun you stupid sons of
foreign
I'm telling you in 20 30 years from now
when this generation
becomes adults and they take over this
country and they take over the policy of
this nation
I'm telling you
they're going to take away your
guns dummies
every last one of them not just
the assault rifles not just the
handguns they're going to take
them all away from you every one
of them they are not going to put up
with this
they're not going to make their children
go through the they went through
they're just not gonna do it
and if you think that this generation is
going to grow up and not do something
about it so their children do not have
to do what they did they don't have to
run and hide hide underneath desk
be terrified to go to school to learn
these children are not scared of books
you fascist
they're not scared of books nor should
they be they're not scared of drag
queens
dressed up in dresses
they're not scared of your stupid little
pronoun war that you want to have they
don't give a about wokism
they definitely don't give a about
the Deep state
do you know what is on these little
children's Minds
when they have to do drills to make sure
they're not killed
murdered torn apart by bullets their
heads blown off limbs hanging from their
bodies
oh you don't like the graphic images
well you
and it really is Rich it really is
rich I mean it's oh man it's
rich
because anytime this happens and there's
a Manifesto of a white supremacist he's
gonna go kill people of Keller somewhere
in a community somewhere or their hatred
has led them to kill people and we point
that out
and not only do we point that out we
point out why we shouldn't have the gun
policies that we have so people like
that cannot get weapons and you're like
oh well see you're just politicizing it
you're well so we're gonna politicize it
oh they were trans they they were trans
so it's the it's the hormones it's the
med it's there it's the mentally okay
listen listen you dumb we
never just say it's white supremacy is
the gun problem
it's it's the guns
it's it's
the guns
in countries all around the world
there's white supremacists there's
hateful
there are people who commit hate crimes
all around the world because they're
white supremacists are Nazis or
Republicans you know that's what we call
them here
but they don't go mow down
as it's the gun
foreign
person lost their mind and went into a
Christian school and killed little kids
with a gun
I've never said white supremacy killed
people in Buffalo New York today
I've never said that I said a white
supremacist
who hates black people went into a
grocery store in Buffalo New York
because he had the ability to get a
gun and killed people
human beings in a grocery store
who have the right to walk around
without being afraid that they're going
to be mowed down by a weapon of War
that's what the I said I don't know
you can go rewind the tape hell I got
the clip where I go off I I oh
my God you talk about go off well if I
went off on Uvaldi
foreign
I'm sick and tired of being pissed I
really am I'm tired of it
I am just sick and tired of
being pissed about this and I'm I'm
trying this is me trying not to
get pissed off
I had a uh a two-way bro yesterday get
into some comments I might show it to
you here later
he talked about how anyone anyone who
infringes on the second amendment should
be tried it Tracked Down in prison and
tried for treason no mercy no plea deal
listen you 2A Bros they're I
know I know you don't understand what
the word Amendment means and I
really get that you have no clue how
numbers work
so the second one there's also like a
first one and there's I don't know
there's like 27 other ones 26 other ones
I understand you don't know that I I get
it I understand right I understand that
you're you're not you know the
magonomics just don't add up
what's up
but there's more rights not to be
infringed you dumb
and the infringement and using one rat
isn't infringing another
you people really need to get
your head screwed on
because today you're going to use your
First Amendment right to say some dumb
stupid oh the two way Bros are
gonna be out saying some dumb 1A no
doubt they're already doing it
Jesus Christ Marjorie Taylor Green's
talking about how testosterone is the
reason well if that's the case then we
shouldn't give any man a gun
you stupid
but there's no reason not to expect dumb
arguments from stupid people
so when you're out there today
especially if it's face to face
and they say anything anything
about mental illness you just say this
well boy if if they were if they were as
hell-bent on giving people access to
mental treatment Mental Health Care
treatment for mental illnesses they are
guns maybe we could talk
maybe maybe maybe
if the Republicans are or anyone who is
a 2A bro who's talking about mental
illness and trying to pair it up
with trans people
if they would give folks access
to Mental Health Care like they want to
give access to guns well but fire
let's do that
instead they're trying to legislate
people out of existence
and giving everybody guns let's
stir up the hate and give everybody guns
that's a good idea yeah baby let's make
sure they can kill each other
you people are dumb as dog
you're dumber than dog when you're
talking about mental illness
there's not a out there
that is calling for gun reform that
isn't calling for mental health reform
you stupid
and if you don't know that you aren't
listening and you haven't been
listening I want mental health care in
this country for you 2A bro
you're the one who needs a lot of mental
health care we're the ones we're really
worried about you
seriously I'm worried about the
Maga cult
and I would love to get them I I I think
I think we should put it on Elon Musk
and the billionaires tabs that these
Maga cult get mental health care
fast quick and in a hurry I'm for that a
hundred percent and anyone else who
wants it everyone has a little bit of
mental illness if you don't know that or
believe that you are a stupid
you just don't understand how
brains work
and if you're one who I absolutely
thinks your mental health state is the
absolute Peak you're the one we should
really worry about
like you are the one we really should
worry about if you think your
mental health state is the peak Max that
it could be and you have no mental
health problems
that you're the one who's got them bad
okay your delusion is deep
these are human issues it happens to
everyone just like just like sore sore
muscles and weak joints
failing eyesight your hearing's going
out
what the you what the you
think what the you think mental
illness is huh
what the do you think it is
so as we um
reflect ignore and move on because
that's what's gonna happen here
it's what's going to happen because this
is it was just a Monday in the United
States of America it's just a Monday in
Nashville
no big deal three teachers three
students get killed it's just America
baby America
we're here Star Spangled and all that
yesterday was not a patriotic day
yesterday we should be ashamed of
ourselves every last one of us
and I I don't express it that well I'll
admit I get pissed
and trust me in a debate like this
yelling and screaming probably doesn't
help but it's the only thing I
know how to do especially when when
three nine-year-olds get murdered in a
school and my little girl is a
nine-year-old in a school
I get pissed
as any parent should
that expects the freedom to send their
children to school I don't give a
if it's public or private I don't care
if it's Christian or a cult I don't care
those children should be safe
everyone should be safe from these
weapons of war
you scumbags
and if you don't understand that you're
not patriotic
your second amendment isn't what you're
protecting
it's your right it's what you think is
your right not to be wrong
it's your right to to walk around like
you're tough
and that you own this place you don't
you don't
and the more this happens
it's shameful it's tragic more this
happens
the more America is going to be against
your dumb ass
there's plenty of people out there that
own these weapons
plenty of people out there that own
these weapons
today today should be going going and
giving their arsenal of these weapons
away to law enforcement and having them
melt that down
they won't
I can't own guns
I mean I can own them I just can't have
them
that's right
I don't want them
my dad has several weapons
rifles hunting rifles family guns guess
what I'm gonna do if I ever inherit
those guns I'm gonna get I'm gonna chop
those I'm gonna make sure that those
are obliterated
I don't give a what kind of family
heirloom they are they ain't worth
another life
it ain't worth it
not one goddamn not one goddamn second
not one goddamn minute
and I don't I not told my dad that I
said hey
you just might as well go get rid of
those I don't want them
and if anyone in our family doesn't want
them you might just might as well go
melt those some down
as far as I'm concerned they're just a
risk to mine and my family's life
and any other family's life as someone
gets a hold of any kind of weapon
so to all you responsible gun owners out
there today
because I know liberals on just as many
guns as conservatives
this this isn't this isn't a
conservative thing you dummies liberals
own guns too liberals like guns too
to all you people out there
who were saddened by yesterday
and you have a safe full guns our guns
in your house or
guns that someone had access to think
long and hard
about how important
whether you spend a lot of money on them
or they were given to you their family
heirlooms
just think about it
think
how would it make you feel
if one of those weapons kill the
nine-year-old in a school
everybody stick around we're going to
talk about Trump and his interview with
Sean Hannity right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacist the first lesson began
with learning simple phrases and soon I
was putting those words and phrases into
a conversation each lesson takes about
10 to 15 minutes to complete and they're
all really different which keeps things
interesting the app is really smart it
actually keeps track of the word that
I'm struggling with I chose Babble mag
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show I got some more
bad news for you everyone's gonna be
upset about this it's Tuesday this is
Paul Norman joins us but he's on
vacation he was gonna try to join us
can't get the connection
that he needs to uh to join us here
today so I apologize for that I was
hoping I was hanging on to hope I didn't
want to say he wasn't going to join us
until I knew but here we are at the
bottom of the hour and this is Norman
Texas Paul uh joins us so I know stay
with us though stay with us we're going
to talk about these uh these this Trump
interview with Sean Hannity oh my God
you talk about a show he
talks he talks about the ball bat
picture right he talked about the ball
bat picture everyone's saying Texas ball
again I want to say listen I know Texas
ball is usually here on Tuesdays but
he's on vacation and then he just he
just he's not going to be able to join
us today
he's on vacation he was hoping he would
I don't think he's going to
I mean just he can't get enough
connection you gotta have connection to
get into this broadcast you can have
decent internet
so he Texas Paul will not be with us
today
he'll be back next week I believe I
think that's what he said he'll be back
next week if he can't join us this week
he did his show Sunday with Sunday
coffee with Texas ball
um he tried to do it last week from a
hotel room and it wouldn't work like
there wasn't enough connection
um so he won't be joining us today so
foreign
man I I really tried not to get pissed I
promise
I try I try
to
um to do that segment about the shooting
in Nashville
without
um getting too pissed off but
it's just it's almost impossible for me
and it should be impossible for all
Americans
it should be it should be impossible for
all Americans to be quite honest with
you
um
but you know
there is something we can do and and
that is to not let them stop talking
about this
we just can't
we cannot and I'm going to show you a
video of a congressman from Tennessee
this morning
saying there's nothing we can do I'm
gonna show it to you it's gross
it's repulsive but that's who they are
they're gross and repulsive
Republicans are scumbags the
only re the only the only listen there's
only one there's only one reason
why we don't have reasonable gun reform
in this country only one
only one
Republicans
there's there's only one reason
Why women's bodily autonomy is being
rolled back in this country
Republicans
there's only one reason there's only one
reason why books are being banned in
libraries
Republicans
there's only one reason there's only one
reason why we can't actually get access
to mental health care in this country
like we have access to guns
there's there's only one reason only one
just just one
Republicans
there's only one reason only one reason
why children can't be safe in schools
and go to school at the age of three
instead of five start their education
early and relieve parents of that two
years of daycare only one only one
reason
Republicans
there's only one reason only one reason
why our education system is so
underfunded only one
only one
Republicans
one
complaining on anything else you want
you can say oh well it's this or it's
that
it's the billionaires it's the
corporations
do billionaires and corporations vote in
our government
do they
do we elect billionaires to be our
representatives in our Republic is that
what do we do that are are are
billionaires in control of of state
legislators is that who we vote in
billionaires
do we vote in billionaires and
corporations as governors
is that what is that what we're doing do
we vote in billionaires and corporations
as our city councils and our County
commissions is that is that what we're
doing no
you're voting in stop stop voting
for republicans
that stop voting
for Republicans you know what happened
here's what happens in a two-party
Republic we have okay let's just say
that the entire country went you know
what holy holy the reason why
we don't get the majority ideology in
this country the reason why the agenda
isn't pushed by what the majority wants
in this country is because we keep
voting in the people who don't want that
and who are working hard against it so
if we stop voting for those dumb
oh wow it'll change but
here's what will actually happen okay
and this is super important for anyone
out there who does not understand a
two-party Republic
and I can't even believe I have to
give you a fifth grade
civics lesson here
but this is where we're at if
the majority of people and the majority
of governments in this country and I'm
not just talking about the federal
government state governments County
commissions school boards there's all
sorts of City councils there's all sorts
of governments
that are governing bodies
over a certain jurisdiction
if we
stop voting in the people who are
working against our interest
intentionally working against our
interest if we stop voting for them
guess what their party will do because
there's it's a it's a two-party system
in this country it's it's a two-party
system
and and a lot of a lot of States want to
say oh our our city council and County
commissions they're not part I said
the out of here with that
nonpartisan hey you're so full of
judges we're not we're not partisan
get the out of here you think
anything that's not partisan these days
especially with information that can fly
as fast as it can
into the ears and minds of people get
the out of here here's what will
happen if if the if the majority of the
country discovers oh man we're voting
for people who are doing the opposite of
what we want
if the country does that guess what the
second party will do I I think the
Republican parties did I mean we have a
two-party system that's why it feels
like we have such
um angst in this country if you can say
it like that
is because we actually only have one
party he was interested in democracy
in our Republic
only one only one is interested in doing
the work of the people who vote them in
the other is a minority ideology and
they're doing the work against the
majority of people who vote them in they
don't know it because they vote based on
affiliation but if we have a situation
in a two-party Republic where
one party is not being voted in guess
what will happen
guess what will happen
yes guess what just guess I know it's
hard Gabe Sanchez can you tell me what
you think would happen if one party
loses entire power almost entirely
across the country in a two-party
Republican it's only one party getting
elected do you what do you think would
happen
are you saying that Republicans would
lose all their power or that I mean if
they would lose the majority of their
power and they had no levels or levers
of power almost anywhere what do you
think would happen in a two-party
Republic if one party took all the all
the power because the people voted that
way I mean that's what it I mean well I
mean well one is you obviously have the
potential authoritarian government right
let's assume exactly do you think
American people do you think the
American people uh especially with our
attitudes I mean we got this American
attitude right it's the big dick
swinging attitude right yeah that's what
the guns are about that's what that
stupid shit's about
do you think that there is a chance a
chance in hell
that there wouldn't be another party
that would emerge that the pro-democracy
Coalition would go you know what
I'm I'm pro-democracy you're
pro-democracy but you know what we're
kind of on opposite sides of this
and it feels like I'm not in your party
anymore right I mean we're both
pro-democracy we both believe in the
principles of our fundamentals so do you
think do you think what will happen
in our country's history in the next 50
years here's I honestly see this
happening either the Republicans or
get off the pot and realize that their
ideas suck and no one wants them
they're just people are voting based on
affiliation or another party emerges now
that party is going to look very similar
to quote the establishment Republicans
today and part of that party is going to
come from our pro-democracy Coalition
it's going to because not everyone
agrees with me right yeah not
everyone I mean we me and you agree on
most issues I think that's why we work
so well together but there's several
issues we do not agree on at all yeah
and and I just I just cannot believe
that we our country is in a position
where most people
they're more worried about who's going
to pitch today right who who's gonna
pitch today who's pitching today
who's pitching tomorrow well what does
that mean for our record what does that
mean for this series who's going to
throw the football on Sunday are they
going to trade this person from this
basketball team to that basketball team
who's going to win the national title
who's going to win who's going to win
March Madness right they're worried
about that right
but they can't give two flying not
a flying I don't know about how
they're voting based on affiliation
they're just not getting what they want
I mean they get pissed off right I mean
I think a lot of people are pissed off
yesterday yeah yeah I mean like you've
got in obviously I know that we'll go
into this a little bit later but like
we've got people like Byron Donald's
who's like local Google look AR-15 band
let's let's not get emotions don't don't
solve any problems okay the they
don't are you gonna honestly tell me
that emotions cannot be used for good
and cannot be used to actually push
forward legislation I'm pretty sure
that's exactly how legislation has
worked to enact change for the good of
our country some happens some
injustice some group uh you know is not
represented and then there's a movement
there are protests there are
um you know rallies there are you know
contacting legislators to actually move
forward
but then for someone to say oh emotions
don't solve don't solve this is you know
or you're getting too emotional or uh
you're too invested in this yeah there's
a reason why and you know like we talked
about yesterday I was like I myself like
my dad's business was a block down he
had to he ended up having to close and a
lot of businesses in the Highland Park
area ended up closing because nobody
wanted to come back to that area of
Highland Park because they didn't feel
safe right the same reason that I know I
have a friend whose cousin
what is that Michigan State right we
have students at Michigan State who have
who have survived two mass shootings in
their lifetime and they're not even
20 years old right we live in a
country
that this is commonplace and Republicans
say um you know it is what it is right
and they try to throw God as like oh
it's you know it's God's plan or
whatever that is and they'll
try to do that with whatever the problem
is it's not just mass shootings right
it's it's the economy it's jobs uh it's
Social Security and other programs that
would benefit us as a as a country as a
whole that we've invested into they'll
come up with some reason some some some
way to excuse their own
um
their own
uh kind of we'll say
uh I'm blanking the word right now
[Music]
um
wow I totally blinked uh
Republican Republicans will will do
whatever they can they they are the ones
who will take advantage of it but wow
I'm totally blanking right now well
here's the thing is that I I'm glad you
brought up the Michigan State because I
said this in the first 30 minutes
selfish it sorry yesterday
yesterday
after uh hearing the the report I
actually ignored the news
for a long time for several hours I I
applaud you I went and walked
um as I do most days I didn't try to
open Twitter
and then I came home and I had some yard
work to do and I thought you know what
I'm going to do this yard work before I
go read the reports and someone a friend
of mine
who normally does not talk politics
message me about this I'm like Jesus
Christ this is bad
when someone who doesn't normally talk
politics much and they're messaging me
and they're wondering I mean and I got
and of course then it starts to because
I was trying to ignore it to be quite
honest with you right because as I said
this morning I'm trying not I'm trying
my best not to be pissed I'm trying but
it is hard it is difficult not
to be pissed off about this because I
have a daughter who's in third grade
who's nine years old
and when um
the only thing I could think when I
started thinking about it yesterday
because as I was finishing up my yard
work that's when the thoughts started
popping my brain
um
the only thing I could think which is a
horrible thought it's horrible
and and it's not something that you want
to think about as a parent I can't wait
for my children to be out of college
I can't wait I can't wait
and and it's so sad that we're we're
hoping for 20 years to pass this by so
that they're out of schools and safe
right
and it just it it
I mean it saddens me that those were my
thoughts that I can't wait for
my children to be out of school because
schools aren't safe
and and then and then um you throw the
whole mental illness and and
transgender and and their and how
they're treating that
um she has pissed me off even
more because these arguments and we're
invited into I was invited into a space
today talk about this issue and I'm
probably going to get banned from that
space yeah today oh I if I go in and
speak I'm probably going to get banned
because I'm going to go scorched Earth
and I'm going to burn down every single
one of those fascist pieces of
in that space
um so I I you know I'm gonna try to I'm
gonna try to keep it under control but
listen I am pissed off
that in this country that is the richest
the wealthiest the greatest country ever
yesterday in Nashville Tennessee
three teachers
and three nine-year-olds
got ripped apart
because we it's us folks I know you
don't want this I don't want it Gabe
doesn't want it we want change but it
it's it is on us yep it's on us
and and we cannot
let these stop thinking
about this I know the Republicans don't
want to talk about this I know they
don't want to mention this the only
thing you want to oh to get Marjorie
Taylor Green's like oh testosterone
you scumbag mental illness as if
every in this country
doesn't have some form of mental illness
listen when they throw the mental
illness thing at you just say well if
when Republicans want access to Mental
Health Care like they want access to
guns then we can talk right you
pieces of garbage
and it's just it's it's
infuriating honestly I I there's not too
many times
that I don't want to say some yeah
yeah but I definitely the internet will
ban me uh across all platforms
if I actually said what I wanted to say
today and I'm holding back this is me
not being pissed folks
um because I am hot about this
as every parent should be that
our schools aren't safe and and we're
gonna um we're gonna talk a little more
about this uh later on I definitely do
not want to miss
some of these clips from the Trump
interview because it is super important
that we keep our eye on the ball as well
because I'm telling you in 2024 if we
let these boneheads take over in
these states and as our president in the
United States we you think you think we
have a gun problem now
it's gonna get way worse
um every single one of these Trump
Republicans in these states are causing
more and more problems
uh with guns because they just want
anyone and everyone to have a gun and
the more guns the better really honestly
the more guns you have in a school the
more guns a mass shooter takes in the
school apparently the safer the school
is because that's what they say more
guns more safety so I mean right we
should we should be encouraging the mass
Shooters to be carrying at least eight
or nine guns as opposed to two or three
I mean by that logic right am I
wrong am I I mean it is pretty pretty
Sound Logic and I wanna I know that
we're going to go to shitless Roundup in
a second and I just want to call
attention to a a person that's on my
list right now oh Don Cobin
so for anyone who wasn't here in
yesterday's show oh Don Coben thinks
that I should be banned for what I said
yesterday now if you go back and you
watch this hey Don Don if you're so
worried about it report it you
right do it but I think Don has a
a bit of a short-term memory loss or or
something because this is what I said
yesterday
when we talked about the shooting I said
we're tired we are tired of this we are
completely exhausted by what is going on
we now live in a country where we are
less than six degrees separated from
someone who has been directly impacted
or a victim of a school or a mass
shooting right I talked about my dad
having and I'll say it's super calm for
Don right now so he doesn't get super
triggered my dad had a business
that was half a block down from the
Highland Park shooting that happened at
a parade in in Highland Park Illinois
right this past year in 2022.
I have close friends whose cousin and
family members go to Michigan State
they were there at the time of the
school they were at the they were there
at the time of the Michigan State
shooting right
again students who are at Michigan State
have now lived through two school
shootings there was a woman yesterday
who was from the Highland Park shooting
a survivor of the Highland Park shooting
and was there vacationing to see her I
think sister or sister-in-law a family
member does it really matter and
it doesn't even matter but it's the
point that it shows you that only in
America can you vacation in a place
where there's a mass shooting after
being a survivor of a mass shooting in
the United States of America we live in
a country where guns outnumber people
we live in a country where where there
is a direct correlation between the
ownership of guns and gun violence
people want to say oh you know what it's
the good guy with the gun that saves the
day well it's not because if you look
back at last year you had Uvalde right a
mass shooting and nearly 400 Law
Enforcement Officers stood by and did
absolute some of them actually went
in and took their own children out
selfishly before getting their before
getting the other kids out you know I
understand you're a parent and that's
the first thing on your mind but at the
end of the day if you're there to
protect and serve your community and you
selfishly go in to get your own children
before letting anyone else in or even
holding parents back from going in who
are willing to go in without bullproof
vests that's pretty telling
and in addition to that when we have
Representatives who have a greater
interest in taking NRA or gun lobby
money than actually helping the innocent
American lives or dead children that
tells you exactly what's going on and
yesterday Don got upset because I was
upset he got under my skin and it's not
that he got under my skin but it's the
fact that this topic got under my skin
it's something that has happened in a
incredibly frequent frequent frequent
manner it's an everyday occurrence
I don't know what dude you can go back
to 47 30 of yesterday good luck I don't
know what would be there that other
people who have witnessed these same
atrocities and travesties would not say
on air
is that they are upset and that they are
fed up with a lack of accountability and
responsibility that our legislators have
well what he's saying because he's
really he's really upset
he's really upset at you and the reason
why I think he's upset at you and the
reason why he's given a time stamp is
because you said God let those children
die
oh I did and you know what you know what
it I will tell you exactly why I
think God let those children die okay
I'll tell you right now hey I'll tell
you hey hey Don get out your time stamp
again you're gonna need another here we
go here we go
you idiot people who use the
argument I also know this is a bit of a
delay here I don't know what's going on
with my camera yeah it's okay anyway so
what I'll say is this
God let those children die okay God let
those children die assuming and look I
was raised Catholic okay I even for a
period of time kind of went into
Christianity when I was high in high
school right
I truly believe if there was a God he
let those children die
because when somebody says oh oh God is
you know he he wanted it to happen it
was planned to happen it was meant to
happen it was God's plan you know what
the real problem was it was the shooters
or it was the shooter's free will
pure demonic is how they'll say it
they'll say that it was it was free will
Man's Free Will and it was the shooters
pure demonic nature of it well here's
the thing
you're going to tell me that that the
the place
if God truly does exist and God truly is
good then you're going to tell me
that God would let a bunch of children
get murdered in a presbyterian School a
religious school you're going to tell me
that that is where that would happen I
guarantee you that's the last
place that would happen if God truly
truly did exist
and if you believe God exists then you
have to accept the fact that God let
those children die because God did
nothing to prevent it now if you want to
make the argument that free will
is what we have control of because God
forbid you know God actually goes in and
controls what we do right that's the
argument you want to make you want to
say that we are actually in control of
our own free will then that would assume
that we have both bad intentions and
good intentions if you say that the the
shooter has bad intentions then we can
also have good intentions which would
mean
that if we have good intentions
as as as owners of our own free will
then we should use those to love our
neighbors and make sure that we protect
them by passing gun safety legislation
and if you accept the fact that we have
free will and when we have good
intentions and that we are not able to
act or that we don't actually follow
through with that then you have to
accept the fact that our legislators our
Representatives our Senators whatever
don't do what's in our best interests
they they have to accept the fact that
there is hypocrisy and that they don't
actually care about the constituents or
their lives or their children
they care more about taking money from
the NRA and gun lobby or gun interest
groups
that would show you that if there really
was
free will
that we could do what we needed to do to
prevent this from happening
and as a result
God let those children die
so you Don well Amanda says it best
here Don's a Karen and Don I want to
address something before we go to the
let's round up here
uh some people said you've tried to
report them and you can report anyone
you want you can report me report game
but if I catch you trying to report
people in my chat just because you get
your little snowflakes feelings hurt I
will ban you quicker than I don't
have a problem with timing people out or
Banning them I want to address this
while we're on this topic if you are
here are the hate watch be have at it
have at it baby and you you can come
after us however you like I don't give a
I can take it and if you're an ally
here and you're stirring here or in
another chat and I find out about it
I'll ban you two I do not give a damn
because here we are going to have
conversations and here we are going to
tell the truth yes it's a little
raw it's a little hard and sometimes
when we bring people up like Don Karen
here oh wait excuse me is that his name
I know his name is Don Karen
when we bring that up I'm telling you
I'm not going to go easy on you so if
you're hate watching and you get in the
chat and you think I'm gonna go easy on
you because you're a dumb well then
you're mistaken you're highly mistaken
but if you if you with my
viewers if you with the people who
are watching this show if I find out if
I know and I really don't care if you're
Don Karen or anyone else
anyone else if you're stirring
anywhere if you're stirring here in
the chat I don't give a and if my
moderators are timing you out or Banning
you
and you have a problem with that you
have a problem with me
that's what I'm telling you if you have
a problem with anyone who times you out
or bans you you can go ask that
moderator why there's nothing wrong with
resolving an issue because our
moderators are the best moderators in
the world they will resolve an issue for
you I guaran damn see it telling you I
got the best moderators in the world
I'll make sure of it
but if I don't care if you're an ally or
if you're Don Karen here you're you're
some hate Watcher you can come here you
can chat you can say real raw things if
you're with you're with
our viewers
you're with me
especially for Jack women are moderators
then you're really jacking with me right
so
um I just want to be clear on that that
the rules are my rules and my rules are
respect the people in the chat and
respect the moderators you don't have to
respect me I don't give a that's
why I'm here every day you're gonna hate
me are you gonna love me you're gonna
love me or you're gonna love to hate me
either way right so so so get it
straight just just know
that um here at in the chat it is it is
a place that you can come and engage
because it is the best chat in the
goddamn world this is the most engaged
chat for as many people as we have
there's no other there's no
other channel out there that's got 15
000 subscribers and has four
1400 people 1600 people show up every
day live ain't gonna happen go find it
for me I mean even yeah I was gonna say
even I mean like yes we have the best
fans and we also have the best haters
yeah dude you know for some I just want
to point this out for someone like Don
right he comes in here and he gets all
riled up he watches two hours a day
right every day in the day thank you he
pumping the comments oh yeah I
mean I'm insensitive I'm sorry that I'm
insensitive about children dying
sensitive and and gun violence in this
country being something that has to be
taken care of I'm so sorry done I'm so
sorry that I said God let those kids die
because here's the thing he did he did
if you really believe in God he let
those kids die and I'm sorry but that's
the truth of it and Don I I want you
here every day yeah but if you're
reporting my viewers you can report me
all you want I don't give a people
can come after me I I don't know if you
noticed this or not but I will take
incoming fire from a chat from tweets
um from accusations leveled against me
about my past I don't give a bring
it on that's why I have the Michael he's
leaving hold on
you can't apologize so you won't see me
again yeah I won't I won't say I'm sorry
for you being a dumb so yeah
sayonara don't
where the good Lord splits you there
he'll be back tomorrow yeah he'll be
back he'll be back all right everybody
we're gonna go to the list Roundup
uh stick around because we're gonna go
to these Trump clips and I got some
clips I got a clip You're Gonna Love A
Marjorie Taylor green Gibson oh you're
gonna love this glitch oh I think I
there's oh yeah but yeah totally yeah
you know you know which one I'm talking
about yeah all right everyone let's
let's get to the shitless Roundup but we
round up all the Tweety tweets the
trendy Trends start to count down
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of all the Tweety tweets and trendy
Trends as long as Twitter still exists
did you hear on April 1st he's gonna
destroy the bonehead of the week of
Poland no April 15th we have almost
April 15th oh 15th yeah yeah so he's
gonna destroy I know I don't know if you
guys know this now we're gonna have it
on YouTube right but Elon Musk is going
to destroy the um the possibility to
pull on Twitter for bone end of the week
it's not it's not my fault yeah you got
it because here's the thing it's not
only us I'm what he said was you have to
pay to participate in a poll yeah so so
we can put up the poll but the only
people who can vote in the poll are
people who pay yeah if you pay the eight
dollars a month then you you know if you
pay you play right that's what it is so
guess what I'm gonna not do put up polls
for people to pay to take them I'll I'll
put up a poll on YouTube you know should
do is we should put up polls but then we
should link out
to YouTube it's a good idea come vote
here hey that's a good idea so we'll do
the bonehead post and we'll link out to
the right to the poll on YouTube
because we have no other choice at this
point don't do a poll on Twitter
yeah actually you know we should do a
poll we should do a poll
um
and and say are you a blue check cook or
no I'm going to YouTube to vote like
that should be the bowl no are you a a
blue check cuck or no I'm going to
YouTube to vote and that's how you
should be able to vote and obviously
there won't be anyone in the no category
because you can't vote if you're not
blue check verified yeah you don't pay
him a bucks and you know there's some
people that are buying blue checks and I
don't blame them like it's part of it
they they're almost gonna have to have
this thing for what they do with their
account I mean technically and I thought
about it yesterday when I was thinking
about this I was like man what if we
just bought a blue check for the Pod
account that way we could right right
but but it's not going to solve anything
if he won't let people vote right
Elon Musk Elon Musk is all about
transparency and and leveling the
playing field and making sure that
everyone has a voice and Twitter being
the town as long as you pay him as soon
as you make up his loan money that he
has to pay the bank then you're good how
how long do you think it'll take for him
to to not have this uh this because he's
going after polls which is an easy one
right because a lot of people don't post
polls right I mean I'm sure that the
amount of percentage from people why I
mean the amount of percentage of regular
post or media post versus polls polls
are probably like below one percent of
all tweets that there are I'm
sure it's really I mean I don't actually
know the numbers I'm just saying it's
probably really low like
surprisingly low is probably how yeah
yeah I mean like so it's an easy target
is what I'm saying yeah even with this
easy Target and the way he's doing it I
would bet he he he changes this
by April 15th where he's like well she
it's it's actually
it's not I'm not gonna have because
yesterday he was like this is
of the bot problem and then he was like
but Bots that do pay me they can vote so
we'll let those Bots vote like yeah well
he was like he was unpaid verification
actually addresses the bot problem and
increases the increases uh the
difficulty by ten about ten thousand
percent okay one that's a made-up number
and two the idea that you think that a
because keep in mind paid verification
doesn't actually verify that you are who
you say you are it just means that
you're using a credit card because you
know let's say that I on my it could be
a burner card right you know on my
credit card it says my name right
however on my Twitter account I don't go
by that name let's say right I can make
up a John Doe 69 name right
right and I could go with that just
again it's not verified anymore it's
verified that you've given Elon Musk
your payment information that's it the
only way because then it comes into this
situation which is then if he says oh
well then only way to verify is to do it
through your your license right or your
your ID okay let's assume that people
actually go through with that again you
still have the same issue just because I
have that name on my legal document
doesn't mean that I go by that name it's
like has anyone ever seen a
actor in Hollywood they have stage names
that aren't actually they're legal names
yes it hey it happens
people people are mad about all that
there's there's Anonymous accounts on
Twitter that get super mad about my name
Tony Michaels oh they get super pissed
about it oh they're they're
pissed they're pissed it's hilarious
that's not your legal name like right
dude it's it's it's a show man and it's
an account and you're anonymous you're
anonymous account who is not have your
legal name on your account you're mad
that I don't use get the out of
here so I I'm using a pseudonym you're a
dumb son of a yeah or you are
stupid
um speaking of stupidity
speaking of stupidity and dumb sons of
hmm
so last night Sean handed the interviews
Donald Trump now I think this
uh interview is for one thing in one
purpose only
is that his attorneys went to him about
the ball bat post where he's a picture
of the ball bat where he's holding the
ball bat and Alan Braggs on the other
side on his true social I think his
attorneys went to him and said hey this
is going to be a really bad problem when
we get yeah here's the problem too late
right he's gonna they were like this is
gonna be a horrible issue you need to
get rid of that immediately and you need
to not say anything about it ever again
ever don't bring this up and Donald
Trump was like well hmm
let's go do an interview about it
like like that was his instinct when his
lawyer lawyer not to do something
they're like look you does it you
you play it safe you need to know right
uh implicate yourself in this any
further right okay we'll just play it
off as oh you didn't know what was going
on and it was posted or somebody else
posted on your behalf or we'll figure
something out right just don't just
don't don't
just don't add any more fuel to
this fire
and we'll deal with it right and then he
was like Yeah well yeah let me go get my
gasoline let me go get the gasoline Sean
Sean and I were talking and we think
this is a great way to handle it the
other thing about this that I want to
point out before we watch these oh my
God in these clips because I didn't
watch the whole interview because
that double down yeah
triple D
um so
the other thing about this is when him
and Sean Hannity are talking right it's
have you ever watched a parent like with
a a really a child is very difficult
with behavior right like yeah yeah
they'll fly out the handle yeah my
little brother was there right okay so
so when your mom or your dad was trying
to handle your little brother yeah they
would speak to him in a certain tone
they were trying to like especially if
they were in public they're like look I
just don't want the Meltdown to happen
right here right now like later the
Meltdown can happen like we're in
private and we can deal with it but
right now in public where there's
cameras and lights and all this stuff
and we're gonna go live I just don't
want him to melt down so Sean Hannity
his tone and it almost feels like like
before they went on air him and Sean
Hannity were going at it like and he was
eating Sean handed his ass
probably about the text message that
Sean Hannity
sending and John Hannity's like oh my
God this guy is gonna lose his in
mind and you can tell that they probably
gave him some sort of drugs to hold the
lunatic in right like he's trying to
like this morning I was trying not to be
pissed right right yeah yeah and he was
really trying to hold the lunatic in
right yeah as I was this morning I I'm a
lunatic on the issue of children getting
killed in schools I mean it's hard that
you would assumed that people wouldn't
be right right and it's hard to assume
that Trump wouldn't be a lunatic when
he's a caged animal like this right and
it shows through on these clips but this
first one I'm going to show has to do
with the ball bat and his explanation of
it this is wild this is
wild stuff and this is this explanation
is exactly why I know his attorneys were
like don't say anything and he's like
yep then we're gonna go we're gonna go
put gasoline on the fire listen to this
so with all this information that came
out in your favor
you talked about death and destruction
and then you the baseball bat picture
yeah next to Alvin Breg and you did take
that down yeah and my only question is
why open yourself up to criticism you
have to understand that when the story
was put up I put up a story we didn't
see pictures we put up a story that was
very respiratory very good story from
the standpoint of what we're talking
about oh yeah very good story it's great
story best story ever it was the best
story in history now I want to point out
something also in this out shot in this
um because
not only did his attorneys tell him not
to do this when he when he decided that
it was a good idea they were like here
here's some notes that we want you to
have right because there's some
you're not gonna wanna say yeah um
because it's gonna be used against you
in a Court here eventually
because you're gonna be indicted and
folks I I want to touch on this real
quick and then yeah I thought folks he's
going to be indicted in the Manhattan
DA's office there's no question he can't
stop freaking out about it he can't stop
talking about it he's forgot about Jack
Smith and Fannie Willis at this point
all together and I believe the reason
why is because this Manhattan DA's case
is getting worse and worse and worse
against him and for anyone that was out
there like oh these are the weakest of
the charges need to change their tone on
this because this is not a weak charge
this is not a weak charge it's not just
gonna go away it's not gonna be the
least of his worries this is a big worry
for him is holding notes
he's told notes so what were you gonna
add there no I was just gonna say that
uh so Trump uh you know because we were
chatting last night about this the fact
that Trump goes oh well when I posted
the the article or the link there was no
uh thumbnail
wrong eh wrong I'm literally on the way
back the the web archive okay going back
the way back machine I've looked up this
National file article that says just 10
of Manhattan residents voted for
anti-trump D.A in 20 had it from the
beginning it's had it from the
beginning there is so because here
here's the way that people well here's
the way that the internet works
uh but besides the fact that it's
forever and there's always a trace of
something when you write an article
right A lot of the time if not always
there's going to be an image that you
include or a video you include as a kind
of hey this is a kind of encapsulator
and summarizing what this article is
about this photo that was him with the
baseball bat which he's going to try to
explain to be like oh what was in the
white house doesn't matter the
image of Donald Trump looking in the
direction of Alvin Bragg who's got this
like whoa don't do this look right this
has been here from March 20th when it
was originally posted okay it's been
here from the beginning it never changed
it was always there so when he posted it
days later right
it was there when he did it it was there
immediately when he did it right the
thumbnail was there because the only way
that the thumbnail because there's
another way that could happen right the
thumbnail isn't there so then
oh yeah it looks like you guys are
breaking news keep going I'm gonna look
up this break so yeah so what I'm gonna
what I'm saying here is uh uh there
would be no way that it was not there
already right so when he posted it the
thumbnail was generated because it's
part of the meta uh content that's there
right there's a title description
there's other tags that go with it to
help with SEO that image was there from
the very beginning
so when Trump says oh I don't know it
was there when I posted oh I have no
idea
it's
okay so I'm trying to find this uh news
will you track that down when I go um
yeah yeah back to uh thanks for the
alarm there
um I'm gonna go back to this and then
we'll get to the Mike Pence we'll see if
we can track that news down uh here's
where he explains why he was holding the
bat in the picture in the first place
Gabe as if it matters let's
listen
and they put up a picture of me they you
know where I was holding the baseball
bat it was at the White House oh wow
make America by America because they did
a lot of buy America things oh okay so
Gabe Sanchez he really he thought we
believed
he thought we believed that he went to
the Manhattan DA's office stood next to
Alan Bragg and held the ball bat next to
him well that's how dumb he thinks
people are or that's how dumb Donald
Trump is I don't know I guess uh both of
them are correct because he loves the
uneducated and right I'm sure that no
the poorly poorly or the poorly of
course the poor the poor Leah don't
offend anything Watchers in the chat get
it right get your facts he loves the
poorly educated like Don Cobin
um right and and loves to say how those
are his people right those are his
people so I'm sure that he also believes
that those poorly educated people will
believe him when he says oh yeah I
wasn't actually with the fact that he's
like I was you know trying to assume or
or present the cases like I wasn't
actually with Alvin Bragg that's crazy
those are two separate images right yeah
we know that it's called a composite you
put the images together and they put it
on the website he says they he says they
but you retwe you reposted it but look
at him looking down in his notes see
that you see that he's looking at it
don't say yes say this don't say this
but let's let's um let's continue here
and this is a company that makes
baseball bats then they put next to that
picture a picture of Alvin Bragg I
didn't do it they did it the oh hey I
guess yeah in the paper or somebody put
pictures together but I was holding a
baseball bat in order to promote Maiden
who wasn't on your post of Truth Source
no no what they did is we posted the
story but they had a picture up but they
then put a picture up or the picture was
put up that nobody noticed
with two separate pictures I was grandpa
really needs to learn that for a guy who
knows how to incite the internet he
really needs to learn how it works I'm
just saying yeah they put the paper
there I don't know how it got there and
the pit in the picture and it's a see
it's I was holding the bat in the white
and the and and the thing is see I'm I'm
not I didn't actually I mean I
threatened but I didn't see see please
don't probably
and he got in he's like I'm gonna and of
all the things they're like this is the
thing that I'm really gonna get him with
they changed they changed the photo that
was that was that's it that's what it is
it had to be what it was and they're
gonna shut down the entire country in
its election interference because of it
let's listen made in America you make
these baseball bats instead of sending
over to Japan and China and all other
places oh God I can't even believe it
like he's like how can I work in the
words China baseball bat made in America
China baseball did you know that China
doesn't plays beta
he's like You Gotta Buy You Gotta Buy
America that's why you have the bad I
ended up in the White House see the
crazy thing is is in Japan baseball is
really popular yeah South Korea
Japan super popular right but when he
said Japan he was like oh Japanese
Chinese same thing yeah that's right
that's what that's why he's that's why
he said it like that same thing the same
thing the same same but different same
thing oh my God this is what they made
this was a company good company that
makes baseball bats and other things
like that do they make baseball bats
Gabe does this and other things like
that does this company make baseball I
can't figure out if he knows that this
company makes baseball bats I guess he's
I guess he's under the impression that
that this company makes baseball bats
and other things well uh similar things
yeah yeah right but baseball bats
definitely this company whoever it is
definitely makes
Bats baseball bats baseball bat right
yeah yeah right baseball bats is what
the baseball bat company makes when
they're making the baseball bats yep yep
right okay good America they took that
picture from the White House and they
put it up and then they put a picture of
Alvin brega I will say this with death
and destruction I didn't say death and
destruction yeah you did you did you did
say that yeah you you did quite
literally you type that out I mean
here let me let me go back I'll find the
screenshot and okay I said I'm afraid
yeah I said I'm afraid that if they do
this which is a fake prosecution now you
notice he looks down at his notes again
I said I'm afraid so this attorney's
like look this is what you have to say
if you're gonna go say this stupid
because again an attorney would never
attorney would never ever recommend that
Donald Trump
say this at all yeah never what an
attorney would do is they would actually
write a letter to Alvin Bragg saying hey
he deleted the post this is what
happened they would explain it his
attorneys would explain it and he would
and he would make they would the lawyers
the lawyers the people who are in charge
of defending him from the criminal
prosecution would be in charge of the
narrative that would happen to Alvin
Bragg the Manhattan D.A over this
miscommunication apparently and this
internet fupa here whatever you want to
call it where he they he didn't post it
post a picture the article is great but
the picture wasn't and and the picture
in the baseball bats in Japan China
baseball bats China
yeah an attorney would be doing this not
him but let's keep going we're my worst
enemies say that he's totally innocent
no no they don't believe people that
have never been positive to me or
defended me that don't like me they're
on the other side of the world uh these
are people who said you can't do this
prosecution it will cause tremendous
problems I didn't say do something bad I
say I am afraid that people will do
something because people are very uh uh
look I didn't say people will should you
I said people will do Frank like like
come on man I mean like look I I sent
you that I sent you the uh the
screenshot of his post okay so he's
trying I mean like well he's like oh I
didn't say I didn't say I would bring it
or it would happen I said maybe people
maybe people would do that it's not what
he says though okay what he says is his
long-winded what kind of person can
charge another person a prosecutor uh
uh with a crime you know a criminal yeah
for sure you're a criminal when it is
known by that no crime has been
committed and also that potential death
and destruction and such a false charge
would be catastrophic for our country
question mark
but she never uses question marks then
often right always yelling so but you
know it's just one of those things that
Trump is living in this like revisionist
uh fairy tale where he goes well I mean
he has never said that let's be clear he
has to here and the reason why he has to
here is because his ass is in a ringer
here yeah this whole ball bat thing I
mean it doesn't help like he can say
whatever he wants I mean you know
telling the truth well yeah but here's
something here's what I'm here's what I
say though is that the reason why his
ass is in a ringer here and I believe
that it's he's in big trouble with this
Alvin Bragg ball bat thing yeah is
because I believe
that the the thought that Donald Trump
wasn't obstructing this investigation
and that Alvin Bragg has no evidence if
he was obstructing which there's not a
chance in the world that I believe that
Donald Trump wasn't at least trying or
thinking about obstructing this
investigation and also there's not a
chance in hell that I believe that Alvin
Bragg hasn't found that evidence if it
exists right when you go to trial
and if Alvin Bragg brings an obstruction
charge against this guy
an obstruction of justice trying to shut
down this investigation trying to
intimidate I don't know maybe Witnesses
maybe people who work in the DA's office
yeah and maybe the jury themselves right
and and Alvin Bragg do you can now
submit that post in court as evidence of
what Donald Trump's motivations and
mindset were yeah I mean he he laid it
out you know for a guy that claims to be
a stable genius he's a
okay because no one else in their right
mind would say oh look I'm being
investigated for these crimes you know
what I should do is I should basically
write on my digital my digital diary for
everyone to see about how Alvin Bragg is
a big meanie pants and he's being very
very mean to me and how this is so
unfair and if he comes after me they're
going to be severe consequences the
consequences gonna be death and
destruction and I don't want to see that
happen but if he comes for me don't be
surprised if that happens that's
literally a threat Threat by you saying
look I don't I don't want to see that
happen but if you do it then it's gonna
happen right and and we know obviously
that
his his followers love to read that
digital diary and follow through with it
I mean look at all the death threats
that Alvin Bragg and his team has gotten
already not to mention the white powder
that was sent in an envelope on Friday
well again and this is this is just more
evidence if there is obstruction that
they're going to use
um I want to go to the news real quick
and then we'll jump back to the clips uh
here is uh Mike Pence story uh Mike
Pence must testify about conversations
he had with Donald Trump this is
important conversations he had with
Donald Trump leading up to January 6 a
judge rules this is why it's important
if you read this here A federal judge
has decided that the former vice
president Mike Pence must testify to a
grand jury about conversations he had
with Donald Trump leading up to Jan six
now the judge does say and it's a ruling
that it Still Remains under seal that
Pence can still decline to answer
related questions of January 6 that has
to do with him serving as the president
of the Senate so that's very important
that's very Gordon in this case manner
which means which means that the
obstruction part is still a Donald Trump
obstructing is still at play here in the
Mike Pence testimony right uh Pence
obviously still has the ability to
appeal but it's not going to probably go
very far as Donald Trump has not been
able to win these executive privileged
oh yeah executive privilege is
the same as the crime fraud exemption
you can't hide behind attorney client uh
privilege and the executive privilege I
mean it's what Lindsey Graham tried to
do in Georgia and then we found out that
he was like look if somebody told Trump
that aliens were real he would have
believed you like that's the type of
stuff that Lindsey Graham did not want
coming out and I'm sure there's plenty
more in that in the Fulton County
Georgia uh investigation in that that
case right now but that's the reason why
they don't want this stuff to come out
because they're gonna I they're gonna
show that Trump is this crazy deranged
idiot who is hell-bent on keeping his
own power and doing whatever he can to
do so and the conversations he had
leading up to January 6th are going to
be very revealing
um and and that's why a lot of these
people like Pence and Lindsey Graham
unsuccessfully trying to argue well you
know it's the Merit of the law and you
gotta understand how it's written in the
Constitution and this is why I'm
protected from saying these things no
man you're not protected you're not
protected you up and you were
privy to information and now you have to
reveal that information
or admit that you know I don't want to
perjure myself I plead the fifth like
once you start talking like that we're
gonna know exactly what's going on
because we already know that they know
stuff but they're unwilling to talk
about it right well and it goes back to
Grandpa poopy pants here talking about a
two-tier justice system right that's
what they they have up on the Chiron
here even and again I've told you time
and time again there is a two-tier
justice system in this country and what
these white Republicans are terrified of
is that their tier is not going to
protect them anymore that's what they're
terrified of if it won't protect Trump
like if they're their second tier of
Justice won't protect trump it won't
protect them that's what they're
terrified of now he's talking about it
here in the best well it's just watching
I'll show it to you the whole thing with
Russia because they knew by that time
that the dossier the famous dossier was
garbage it was made up by Hillary
Clinton and the Democrats and the DNC
no they didn't they took this thing and
they sent it around to everything and it
was totally made up and now everybody
agrees to that
somebody should have been prosecuted for
that and you know what it should be this
group that does because now they have
all of the information whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa with the political
prosecutions here Grandpa
what in the wait wait I thought I
thought Donald Trump and the Republicans
in this country don't want political
prosecutions I thought that's what we've
been hearing we've been hearing that a
lot that's what they say and they say
that a lot of people are saying let it
be burst things
that we don't want political process but
he's saying he wants a political
prosecution that's what they want
just so you know just so you know
political prosecutions bad for me but
good for you
know I mean let me go ahead go ahead go
ahead I was just what I'm going to say
is you know again it's one of those
things where it's like it's projection
right they don't want
themselves investigated they want to
investigate the people who are
investigating them for the crime
you break like do do you do the crime
you do the time okay right it's that
simple man you guys are the party of Law
and Order and back the blue and
we gotta respect the law and you just
gotta comply then just do those things
right just comply right follow
your own advice it's a knee on your neck
ah man listen so here's the thing
is the dossier if you want to like talk
about fox facts about the dossy there
are some things in the dossier that are
questionable there are some things
because they cannot be verified right
that doesn't mean they're not true they
just can't be verified there's no
verification but the Democrats didn't
didn't pay for the dossier that's
nonsense Republicans paid this
as op-ed again our opposition research
against it when in the primary that's
who started the whole thing was
Republicans not Democrats yeah that you
fools so so when they throw the
Dashie at you you if they say it's all
untrue tell me the parts that aren't
true tell them tell me what's not true
tell her tell me how there wasn't any of
this Russia Russia Russia collusion
because there was right several counts
because we all have to remember that
before Robert uh before before Mueller
could release his report Barr came out
and goes I didn't see anything wrong
there's nothing wrong it's all good and
then Trump went out and was like look
I've been totally Vindicated it proved
that I was innocent but that's the
opposite and then we found the redacted
version and we're like oh there was and
then you realize that the conversations
that were happening emails sent to Don
Jr being like look we've got some
information that you might want and he's
like how soon can we meet right all of
these people were having these
conversations back Channel conversations
with Russia uh with Russian intelligence
or or connected groups who were trying
to get information right when Trump was
like oh I've Rush is listening I hope
you find those 30 000 emails there are
several accounts of Trump trying to use
Russia
to his Advantage just like Russia was
using Trump to their advantage right
right well and this goes back to the
whole where they're like Paul manafort
gave gave election data to the Russians
like yeah that's collusion yeah and
they're like yeah but oh so he can't
just get this they can't just get this
data on they're like no it was internal
data for the Trump campaign right you
were sharing internal data that you
weren't sharing with the public with the
Russians yeah weird why are you doing
that right right well it's just it's
just election polls and they want to
Scout and they're like oh but the
dossier is not true okay which part of
it isn't true boneheads which
part which part is not true Point them
out to me show them to me they can't
because they don't know anything about
it they don't know anything about the
dosage they know anything about the
Russia collusion all they know is no
objection no Collision no instruction no
Collision idiots okay let's
let's um let's go to the next clip here
uh because that one's pretty much done
um let's see oh oh this one's this one's
great he tried to dig into Rhonda santis
again so I was wrong about what he was
going to do with Ron DeSantis um on
stage at the Waco wacko Nazi rally over
the weekend
I thought he was gonna totally burn that
guy down and just piss on his ashes now
my my assumption in that was that I
thought Donald Trump would go ahead and
strike uh Ron now he would go and strike
him but my assumption was wrong and the
reason why my assumption is wrong is
because I really underestimated how much
he fears that his cult will follow Ron
DeSantis right he is totally fearful of
that that they'll that they'll
jump from him to Ron yeah and in that
fear on Saturday he tried to float his
little arguments about Ron about the oh
he cried in front of me and he begged me
oh yeah he's definitely worth shopping
he's workshopping the stories right and
he's attacking his material here right
so when he went out on stage on Saturday
he didn't he didn't have his material
ready obviously so he was working out
the material and here he is on Sean
Hannity working on that same material
about how Ron DeSantis is a is a
ass and he came crawling to him
and Ron DeSantis wouldn't be right
without Trump listen to this so what
happened with Iran is the following he
came to see me he was getting killed he
was being crushed Adam Putnam it was
over I have many people that I know that
worked for Adam Putnam they said it was
like a new I hate to use this expression
it was like a nuclear weapon went off
when you were why why is it always with
so many people why I mean why who who
this I think this guy suffers from
mental illness right all the Republicans
are talking about mental illness today
hey hey hey guys
the head of your party he needs mental
he needs mental health care
quick this guy is hearing voices like
crazy it's it's pretty it's pretty
telling I mean there was a so when I was
looking for screenshots today let me
just pull this up into uh
uh really quickly uh I pulled I pulled
today's screenshot for the thumbnail
from a clip of of uh Donald Trump with
um
with Sean Hannity right and the
the image or sorry the Chiron as it read
was
coming up tomorrow Trump on Biden's
cognitive decline
[Applause]
featuring the guy who's in an incredible
cognitive decline Donald Trump well I
mean he's an expert on cognitive decline
yeah no he is anyone it takes one to no
one else right right I mean maybe that's
how they Define an expert over there at
Fox News oh this this clip gets way
better when he's talking about but you
know the disappointing thing that Donald
Trump the material that he's not working
out that I want him to work on so badly
is the is the the pudding fingers why is
he not why is he not going after the
pudding fingers right like dude that's
an easy target I know man he's getting
bad he's not getting he's not as good as
he used to be at this I wonder if he's
he's not he's not throwing he's not
throwing everything right now right I
wonder if he's yeah but see this yeah
but see here's the thing is once Donald
Trump sees a Target yeah and he can get
these these toothless brainless
idiots these these Maga zombies to latch
on them maybe he knows that his cult
eats chocolate pudding with three
fingers so he knows if he attacks if he
attacks Rhonda santis then he's actually
uh he's attacking that's good right as
if he gives a about them but let's
let's continue good point but I don't
think he gives that much of a about
them let's keep going who endorsed
because they considered the race to be
over they had the race he had millions
and millions of dollars and he was way
up in the polls he was beating Ron by 30
points or so it was over
Ron came to see me tears in his eyes
he said I need you to do me a big favor
first he asked for the meeting then he
asked me for the favor
I said what's the favor
would you endorse me
I thought he was going to say can I blow
you like I know
like when he was he was working up to
this I thought he was like well I want
you to endorse me but can I uh you know
I mean he eats pudding with his
fingers what am I supposed to think I
mean they're already lubed up I guess
but what am I supposed to think the the
thing that also makes me uh kind of
think about this is
the way he's telling the story
I'm I'm I I could be wrong
but the way in which he's pitching this
story right now
it feels like it's going down a road of
The Godfather okay where he goes look he
came to me with tears in his he came to
me with tears in his eyes and he said
please please I need your help right
he's gonna be he's gonna say at some
point look I gave him I said to him he's
gonna he's gonna be like he came to me
and asked me for a fit he said he gave
me enough I couldn't refuse right he's
gonna he's gonna dude it's gonna be one
of these moments where he's gonna tell
the story and he's gonna basically just
steal the the little monologue
from The Godfather
and he's going to talk about how
he came in asking him for a favor he's
like you come here on the day of my
daughter's wedding right which funny
enough you know could have been right
right uh but the idea that I think he's
going to shift this story again I could
be totally wrong but I really do think
that he's gonna shift this story to be
very like parallel to the Godfather and
he's going to make himself because even
in an interview with Kevin McCarthy
and Don Jr it was his first episode of
his podcast triggered they're talking
about oh my father he feels of himself
or feels that he himself is more like
The Godfather because they were talking
about oh children and all my dad's a
grandfather and like no no he really
believes he's more of a godfather-like
figure right listen just wait John Wayne
came to me and he said please serve with
tears in his eyes this is so stupid
right I I again I actually believe that
he doesn't remember this like he doesn't
remember this but the people around
because he didn't give a about Ron
DeSantis he didn't give a who the
governor of Florida was he could care
less that's why he backed the guy who
was gonna lose right right now what he's
trying to say here and he and he's he's
working through this material because
he's trying to say Ronda Santos is a
box and Ronda Santos would be a
nobody if it weren't for me me right the
only reason why he's the governor is me
the only reason why anyone knows Rhonda
Santos is me and I can't wait for him to
start saying he's copying me he's
wearing my suits he gets his hair he
gained weight to be as fat as me he's
doing it leans like right he sits like
me he wears a diaper like me right right
this guy I mean watch right you know
what that dog that's what it is Donald
Trump eats pudding with three fingers is
it a fascist thing is it a fascist thing
I don't know I've never had the urge to
eat pudding with my face I don't want to
imagine that because I I feel like I've
seen it too many times with like
children eating pudding you know see
here's the thing on the pudding yeah you
know real quick if I can
Ron dude there is a foil
wrapper on the top of the snack pack
right now I don't know if they served it
to him in a snack pack I'm assuming this
I mean I I don't know if there's a
there's a foil there's a foil wrapper on
the top of the snack pack man now
um if you've ever been you know any kind
of engineering mind at all
someone would say should I eat this with
my fingers
who or should I should I try to fold
this foil top yeah like the least I can
do right is to fold it into like a like
a spoon you know type thing that way I
can eat the bread no see Tony that would
have that would imply that uh there was
some thought into it oh I feel like what
happened is he ripped that thing
open through it still had some pudding
stuck to whatever it was behind him and
then he just was like
I just like went in deep and quick right
that's I think what he did the other
thing too is like if even if I was
starving and the snack packs are good
they're good
but even if I was starving like I was
hungry
I'm a hungry guy every once in a while
I would probably wait at least until I
got a spoon to eat the snack even if I
opened it up it's like do I have a spoon
like no like I mean you know do you know
there's another way like if you were
that hungry and you need it you're like
oh I need sustenance right now you open
it up and you just squeeze it and you
get you know you get a fair amount out
because it's a liquid it like you know
right kind of but I mean so even if
you're unwilling to do that or make a
foil spoon out of the foil wrapper on
the top
oh why are you eating it off your
fingers right I don't know I'll admit
I'll admit when I go to like uh Taco
Bell or something yeah I go to Taco Bell
it's Taco Tuesday we're gonna talk about
tacos and I get the nachos and cheese
the cheese is so good I want the
rest of the cheese that's in that cup
that's fine that's totally
understandable that's totally
understandable if you've got peas and a
wrapper eating the cheese with my yeah I
know but I understand what you're like
oh no I stick my finger in there yeah
no no see I won't do that
oh you what would you call me a coastal
Elite but I'm not licking licking my
fingers with cheese on it oh nacho
cheese Elite Okay let's listen to um how
he goes after Ron who is crying he was
sobbing he he begged me he was on his
knees he he had his mouth open Okay
let's listen I fought for you but again
he a lot of people fought for me you
fought for me only rightfully but you
fought for me if you thought I was right
a lot more than he did
I'm gonna shut up I need your
endorsement
I said Ron you're so far behind I can't
imagine that if you've got George
Washington's endorsement combined with
the grade
Abraham Lincoln
tell me about it are those the only two
presidents that he knows
do you think that's the only two I I
honestly think so he only knows those
two questions because he goes George
Washington first President Abraham
Lincoln it's the party of Lincoln he
doesn't know any other president I mean
he knows enough to be like Obama and
right man and Bush Clinton that's it
maybe he probably knows Reagan because
he stole his tagline from Reagan right
American great again so but I'm but I
mean but I mean not in modern history
right so yeah yeah yeah but in terms of
eventually before 19. well before 1920
really or even 1930 right that's he
doesn't really know he doesn't know many
well here it would be good for someone
to say name name me yeah name me
10 10 posts are 10 pre-World War II
presidents you know what I cannot say
Lincoln or Washington you know what I
think uh you know what I think it would
sound like it would sound like when they
asked what types of papers
uh do you read and the question was
directed at Sarah Palin all of them yeah
do you have any specific ones well
you know and he would and I'm sure Trump
would be like oh well uh yeah I mean the
the presidents
um yeah all of them were good right were
they good uh I don't know if uh like
ideology wise or like where your party
sits that you would agree with all of
them right right
I I would I would like to know if he
even knows the president
who was our president during World War
One
like if you just ask him that question
who was the president
during war where he'd be like man woman
camera TV
[Laughter]
he's like I used it I used to test it
I used it okay let's let's hear the rest
of his story he's working on with Ron
here but he said I'm telling you I think
I could win if I could get your
endorsement and he was you'll have to
check the records but many many points
it was over and the nomination just
happened very close the nomination was
just okay
I gave I said let's give it a shot okay
you know you defended me Adam Putnam
didn't one way or the other I think he's
probably you know I haven't met him
until later I I don't know why why would
why would Putnam defend him for what I
don't know well because he's saying
Rhonda Santos is defending him in the
peach because Rhonda Santos was a
congressman right right but I don't want
to be like you defended me but end up on
I mean I don't get it I don't why would
he have to why would he feel obligated
to defend you for that I honest honestly
this is part of the story that I
actually think is the thing that led him
to
um endorse the Santas and what I mean by
that is that his staff convinced him to
endorse DeSantis
be and that's the thing they used like
that's what they because Trump doesn't
think for himself yeah okay and what he
does it's barely bad it's very very bad
for him and everyone else around him so
he doesn't think a lot right so his
staff was coming to him and telling him
you should back to Santa's and they was
like why should I back to Santa's like
well he defended you during the
impeachment he's like yep done like it
wasn't it wasn't Ronda Santa's King
crying and he's like please please
please endorse me please Donald Trump's
staff was like Hey look we need to we
need to pick a guy in this race and we
need to pick a winner and the whoever
you're going to pick is going to be the
winner which isn't always the case yeah
and he's like well who are you gonna
pick like and they wanted Ron DeSantis
they wanted that fascist to be the
Governor right and that's how
they convinced him because they were you
know I think very much you know as Trump
trying to be the Godfather he was like
all right you did a favor for me I'll do
you this solid by backing you but then
at the same time you owe me it's kind of
like when an agent's like you owe me in
perpetuity for any earnings you make
Beyond after the fact of us signing you
get a deal uh sponsorship an
endorsement you go on the show you get
this movie whatever it is I get 10 of
whatever you make and I
think that's Donald Trump right now
where he's like he owes me everything
everything he's done as Governor he owes
because of me right and right now is
what Trump's doing is he's coming back
to be like look pay up give me the
credit that I am due right for helping
you win this election and Rondo Santos
is actually going to be painted in a
corner here because Rhonda Santos is
also gonna have to tell the story if he
gets in this race right if Ron DeSantis
actually enters this race he's gonna
have to tell this story because
someone's gonna someone hopefully
someone will ask him did you cry
did you beg and Rhonda Sands is gonna go
no that fat I did this and
they did this and this is how it worked
right and I hope that's and we can draw
a wedge there because we know Donald
Trump's lying yeah like there's no
question he's lying he's always lying
and Ron DeSantis is a liar too
so what we can do is drive a wedge
through uh the manga cult with with them
two lying back and forth about how this
went and who knows who what and I I hope
I hope someone along the way asked the
question about the FBI too yeah right
the claim was that Trump send the FBI
down to Florida in 2018 to help uh to
help Ron DeSantis win the election now
that's a that's a pretty big
claim because what's happening there is
it sounds like interference and using
sounds like weaponization it sounds like
the weaponization of government and
overreach to ensure that your Party's
candidate wins feels like election
interference using the government I know
we know because of the FBI because
there's a foia request
we know it's because Donald
Trump said it yes yeah we know because
of that right we knew from the very
beginning that it was however I
forget I think it was a news
organization somebody put in a foia
request to the FBI to be like
did you guys go down Florida in 2018 for
the election and then FBI was like well
nope no one was sent there from Donald
Trump we did not go down there for that
so I hope that the pudding
fingers come up I hope that the crying
gets brought up I hope that the FBI
going down in 2018 gets brought up oh
it's gonna be juicy it's gonna be
delicious anything we can do to
put these two again it's gonna be more
delicious it's going to be more
delicious than eating pudding off your
fingers I guarantee it a year later I
met him he said when you did that it was
like a rocket went up he said my race
was over they were already buying
furniture for the for the Governor's
Mansion they were going to win oh
so I said let's give it a shot Ron okay
and he was desperate desperate I said
okay
I gave him a nice endorsement I said you
wearing out what you'd like and let me
see it he wrote it out I thought it was
terrible I changed it medically
from the moment
he blew the guy away the race was over
so so not only does he say oh the guy
came crying to me right but I said yeah
yeah write whatever you want and then I
read it and it was so then I
rewrote it which I'm sure if you go back
and you listen to what Trump had to say
in terms of an endorsement or released
as a as a trump statement uh it was
probably right well it's the same
way that when Jesse Waters has asked
asked Trump to write a book review for
him
that Donald Trump just pulled the review
that was done by the publisher and then
sent it and be like here's my
endorsement of this book that I never
read right well here's here's
the best part about him working this
material because you're going to hear
this a lot
you're gonna hear this one a whole hell
of a lot and and and it has to do with
Ron DeSantis and a pizza parlor this is
I mean it's gonna be Time After Time
After Time After Time After Time he's
going to be saying this every day six
seven times a day he's gonna be truthing
it he eventually will be tweeting it
he'll be standing on stage saying it and
he'll he'll it'll get more wild and more
crazy every time he says it listen to
this
then I had him get him I had to get him
against the star of the Democrat Party
was going to be Stacey Abrams and they
now we call him a crackhead because
that's what he was a crackhead his name
kill him kill him and there was no way
Ron was going to beat Gillum so he got
the nomination but there was no way
because this guy was going to be the
future of the Democrat Party uh and I
said Ron you can beat this guy let's go
I got him the nomination by the way
couldn't have never gotten a nomination
he would be working in either a pizza
parlor place or a law office right now
okay and he wouldn't be very hassle a
pizza part of the police pizza parlor
pizza parlor pizza parlor place right
he's he's not worked there quite
anything but but Republicans Republicans
they have their own feelings about pizza
places well they do but let's listen to
where else he might be working listen to
this look at this guy let's go
I got him the nomination by the way
couldn't have never gotten the
nomination he would be working in either
a pizza parlor place or a law office
right now a law office
a office a piece of murder place
the episode of The Office yeah where
Kevin breaks down the words we're like
you know he reduces the amount of words
in his statement so that he can save
time but then inadvertently has to spend
more time explaining what his statement
was by filling in the gaps so when Trump
goes law office I'm assuming that's his
attempt at also trying to cut down on
the words uh and and save time where
he's like I don't need to say law office
people know people know Law Office all
the time just like I created the word
Caravan I'm going to create the word law
office
he went to work in a pizza parlor place
you don't have to have the place on
there Grandpa It's Just Pizza
like parlor in place are the same that's
the same yeah you know I have to say
both you can say it was a little
redundant but that's Trump right
it's like I'm gonna say as many words
is that what the J stands for is
redundant yeah it's uh Donald uh
redundant Trump with a J right yeah
you're redundant with the J is silent
yeah
he is not he is not silent okay
oh man I I'm not going to be able to
segue back to uh the other stuff now but
I do want to show you this clip of
Marjorie Taylor green
um maybe we'll do I I I honestly I don't
want to be more pissed off uh by leaving
the show today so we're not gonna go
there today we'll go there tomorrow
again uh it'll it'll be out there trust
me they'll still be ignoring it's
definitely not going anywhere because
that's what you know it definitely uh
rinse and repeat you know oh yeah
um so uh Marjorie Taylor green was in a
hearing um with my orcas
um this afternoon this morning this
morning yeah yeah this morning excuse me
um but yesterday afternoon uh there was
a clip of her
um
this is how dumb she is she
thinks she's like got a badge or some
she's like look I'm on the
Overstock committee here's my badge and
the weaponization of the federal
government right overreach of big
government is what this looks like right
so I want to give you a a heads up here
this this gentleman here in what looks
like a law enforcement's jacket which it
is he is uh with the ATF so he is um he
is a festival normal employee who works
for a government agency just like a
normal employee who works for the IRS
right let me let me describe to you what
uh us in the real world would call this
guy a fed he's a cop yeah he's a
cop okay he's got a badge what is the
but for the audience what does the ATF
do exactly well you know there's there's
tobacco and they regulate Firearms as
well oh and alcohol but this has to do
with his regulation on Firearms
um what he's doing is he's going to a
gun store just to check on things right
this is a routine ATF step where they
can they can because you have to have a
license
you can go I don't know man that sounds
like it's getting towards my uh
infringement of my rights my ability to
make a a small or well-regulated militia
right you know it's it's woke to let uh
gun stores make gun stores have license
but a barber or uh someone who cuts hair
and it's not too woke to let make them
have it you know just a thing so let's
let's listen to what Marjorie Taylor
green thinks she has authority over this
Federal Officer it is hilarious and
we're here for the
to also basically hold the government
accountable and when the government has
been weaponized and and people feel like
their gun rights are threatened or gun
or gun dealers feel like their
businesses are threatened
um that's that's where we step in and
make sure that the government is not out
of control
and a lot of gun owners and a lot of
people feel that way emotionally about
you yeah
I love that I love that so so it's like
that's not how we present it though
we're not we're not we're definitely not
saying we're definitely not saying that
we're doing that she's saying we're
doing that but we're not we're not yeah
we don't just so you know we're not
you're not you need to understand that
right this is an obstruction we're not
trying to impede on a federal agent
right going in and doing his job because
that would be illegal right we're not
doing that even though she crazy
over there says we are we're definitely
not doing what she says while while she
was doing that
what was happening in right at that time
in Nashville yeah yeah crazy crazy
um there's another clip and I'm trying
to find it of her in this hearing this
morning and she's talking about the
Canada Border apparently oh yeah I think
Jason and Aaron have those clubs did
they um she thinks she thinks um that uh
she has the authority to stop uh uh ATF
official from going into a gun store she
thinks she has that Authority
um but she also thinks she has the
authority to set border policy for
Canada
I can't even believe that this is the
thing it's it's it's remarkable is what
it is it's wild stuff the confidence
right and and the lack of lack of
self-awareness again it's truly
something this this may be uh more
meganomics here let me see if I can find
this uh clip God damn it there's so many
Clips to her being stupid this morning
no shortage of Clips Tony that one's
stupid I mean literally
no I'm
seriously right there Jason's posting
um several clips of her and they're all
her being dumb as I think they're
economics she's going from one Committee
hearing because they're different angles
yeah she's gone from one committed
Hearing in a room to another Committee
hearing to just jump from one dumb
stupid ass statement to another dumb
stupid ass statement right and she
honestly is like oh man I got those lips
now oh man I own Joe Biden I got
you I'm gonna be on Steve bannon's
Trader TV news show today who's on top
of Carlson last night oh was she well
she's moving up in the world I guess
let's listen to what she doesn't know
about Canada
like to point out that it's extremely
concerning and dangerous to the United
States of America's national security
that Canada's immigration policy allows
Mexicans to travel to Canada without a
Visa it seems that Canada wants to
participate in in Mexico's invasion of
the United States because many of these
Mexicans are obtaining an electronic
travel authorization to fly into Canada
and they get that approved within
minutes and then they end up coming into
the United States
okay so here's the actual story
um because because it is difficult to
get across the border at the southern
border right
um and it's because the bite
Administration is making it difficult to
get across the border I don't know if
anyone's pointing that out that Biden's
the president so it's becoming very
difficult to get across the border yeah
but are there trying to make it very
difficult let me say that
so much so that it's it's become more
affordable for coyotes
to get the ability to have people in
Mexico people in Mexico not Mexicans I
mean some of them may be Mexican it is a
possibility
but people in Mexico to flying from
Mexico to Canada to go across the
northern border that is what is
happening because people want to come in
this country for Refuge
and I don't know I I can't figure out
why they're not talking about why they
want to come here
I mean they want to say oh it's to
murder us like why why who gives are you
telling me that a psychopathic murder
rapist is like you know what I'm tired
of raping and killing around here I want
to go to the United States to do me some
raping and some killing you are a done
you do not understand now the psychosis
of a killer works if that's the
meganomics that you're doing on this
okay you bonehead there are plenty of
people elsewhere besides the United
States for those people who are bad to
do those crimes right and those of these
crimes happening elsewhere right
yeah those people are fleeing to the
United States to get away from those
yeah like that's what
they're trying they're trying to get
away from the people you're claiming
every one of these people coming in this
country seeking Refuge here is you
stupid but you know you're
not gonna get through these people's
thick skills but it it really is
something that she's like look we're not
allies we can't anymore because they're
setting policies that they're trying to
help them Mexicans getting our country
like oh my God so now so now it's gonna
be now this is gonna be the that's
going to start flying around yeah is
that Justin Trudeau is trying to
infiltrate our country right with
Mexicans I mean it's gonna be it's
definitely going to be a topic I mean
it'll probably die down but I mean
immigration is always a topic I think oh
no now we're getting rammed from
both ends you know it's like well do
something then hey here's here's an idea
here's an idea you were elected in a
legislative body right you can pass
legislation it can be you can actually
do the thing where you legislate I don't
know immigration you can do those sorts
of things in Congress like you can do
your job and come to the table
and figure out a way that
coyotes don't have to put people
on goddamn planes to send them to Canada
so they can get across the border right
when you're putting pressure on the
Biden Administration to secure the
border secure the borders secure the
borders secure the border secure the
Border hey hey Gabe guess what secure
the Border hey you know what else secure
the border and the bite
Administration does what you're telling
them to do and you're like whoa now now
that you've secured the Border they're
flying the Canada and they're just
they're just coming down like a
waterfall like Niagara Falls from Canada
like you people are so brain
dead listen these people want refuge in
this country yeah this country has a
kind of a history of giving Refuge to
people and them assimilating into our
society and our economy it's actually
what uh makes us who we are
today like it's it's the reason why
we're an economic world power is because
we were like you know what we should do
we should just be like have the freedom
to where anyone who wants to come here
and assimilate into our country and be a
part of this democracy and have Liberty
and freedom and work towards equality
and equity for everybody then we'll
probably be the most powerful economic
power in the in the entire world
right
it worked or the idea that it's
like hey if we want to actually you know
merger to the green keep in mind that
not too long ago she said uh she didn't
find joy in her job she wasn't paid as
much and she couldn't spend as much time
with her family then resign
about the problems then you gotta go
right you don't you don't complain about
what the problems are without actually
offering Solutions which again is a is a
is a go-to move for Republicans
Republicans will complain about these
deaths and say we got to send thoughts
and prayers and we got to do this but
then on the other end of like what
actually do we do to prevent it they go
nothing they offer nothing right nothing
new hit the snooze and they turn
over and they wait till the next
shooting now on the on the immigration
side like yeah we could actually improve
our immigration policy 100 we could
offer a pipeline to citizenship in this
country we can offer more visas to bring
people in who are talented individuals
that we want to employ in this country
we could make it so that we actually
gain legal citizenship for people who
contribute to our economy that are
already in this country yeah wow economy
well well that but that would mean but
that would mean we'd have more of them
Democrat voters because them Democrat
voters vote against us because we're
bigots okay that's their that's the
problem that they have listen the reason
why it is easier to get uh or someone
who's seeking refuge on a plane to go to
Canada is because our policies at the
southern border are yeah there's
and the administration is dealing
with policies because people like
Marjorie Taylor green are not serious
people yeah they're not serious and
until you dumb out there
who don't like our immigration policy
stop voting Republican stop it stop stop
it vote for people who are serious
they're not Republicans by the way right
those are not because you don't even you
don't look I'll say this you don't even
have to vote Democrat that's not what
we're advocating for well we're telling
you I mean like yes that that that's
your that's the choice right
historically Democrats will actually
have programs and and care for you
however
we're not saying just vote for Democrats
you can vote for an independent for all
I care a green party or whatever
you want right but Republicans 100 of
the time will not work for your best
interests they are selfish they will
work for themselves they will take that
Lobby money they will say oh you know
what those children that died in that
shooting no it is what it is and that's
how God wanted it
you do what you want to do you
my boneheads but I'm telling you if you
want to fix immigration if you don't
want the waterfall of Mexicans coming
from from Canada which is an absolute
ridiculous yeah I can't even believe
that this is the um
the stories that we have to go through
it is a very good sign that our
immigration system is absolute
when they have to fly to Canada to cross
the border and and the northern border
you know how you know how shitty it is
our immigration system must be it is
garbage garbage and you know the
only people that can fix it it ain't the
administration cannot fix immigration
there's only so much the administration
could do and really honestly every time
the administration tries to do something
to either secure the Border or make it
easier for people to come here it's
always fought by every single
Republican attorney general or
governor and they sue them they take
them to court and it's locked up in
court and it continues that policy
continues to not be a thing because it's
locked up in court because of the
question the constitutionality so
Marjorie Taylor green this is a call to
you stop being dumb now I know that's
going to be difficult I know that's a
big ask I mean you're asking for the
impossible here right well but I'm just
saying
if we want serious policy we have to
elect serious people and anyone with the
r behind their name this day and age in
this timeline that we're in just are not
serious I'm I'm seriously I'm being
serious about this baseball bats by the
way baseball bats did you know that
there's a baseball company makes
baseball bats and similar things yeah
similar similar things to baseball bats
that they make for baseball you know
honestly I didn't know that a baseball
company made baseball bats until Donald
Trump tried to explain his non-answer of
why he put up an article that had a
thumbnail that was a threatening image
of Donald Trump holding a baseball bat
with an image of Alvin Bragg which
made you assume that Donald Trump wanted
to hit Alvin Bragg with a baseball bat
oh no we know that he does not that not
that particular baseball bat because
that was a baseball bat he had in the
White House when he was trying to
promote baseball bats right yeah of a
company company who makes baseball bats
similar things right that has baseball
bats and more foreign
oh my God this this is what we have to
deal with folks we are at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life but that's why you come here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific we'll
try to break it down for you every
single weekday same time same place
tomorrow
Surf's Up you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
them
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon